Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I am back on the YouTubes.
Today, oh my gosh, I have a lot of update stuff to go through.
I also, I wrote like a... I usually, for those who don't know...
Sorry, I'm waiting for the coffee to kick in.
I got myself some coffee.
I had to choose between gamer subs or coffee today.
And then I was like, you know what?
I haven't had coffee in a long ass time.
Let's see if gamer subs has fucked me up yet.
And we're like, what do you mean by that, Doki?
Well, I'm really worried that, you know, I feel like almost every time I stream Marvel Rivals, I like grab gamer subs in me to like stay focused and awake.
I'm worried I built a tolerance because of that.
And gamer subs has a lot of, has a lot of like caffeine in it.
So I'm like, well, let's see if, if I'm fucked up forever.
Let's see if coffee still works on me.
So that's what I'm trying out right now.
I'm gonna try and see if the coffee still works.
It is pretty bad because like, um, I usually don't drink caffeine.
But I think like, I don't know.
I almost feel like Marvel Rivals might be bad for me, but I can't tell you.
I needed, I need more, I need more tests to figure it out.
So that means I got, you know, you can't go through a conclusive result.
You can't give a conclusive analysis if you don't go, if you don't have enough results to back it up.
So like, I need more, I need a bigger sample pool, guys.
I need a bigger sample pool to make sure that my hypothesis is correct, guys.
And that's the scientific method.
If any, if middle school taught me anything, it's how to do the scientific method.
Exactly, I need a larger sample size.
So unfortunately, or fortunately, I gotta play a little bit more just to figure it out if it's true or not.
To see if it is bad for me.
Anyway, anyway, I'm not addicted.
I can quit whenever I want.
I say as I start drinking caffeine again.
Anyway, I, for those who don't know, I usually write like, um, things I want to talk about.
And then like this random server that I have that's just for like streams and stuff.
So let me look through.
There's like a lot of stuff I want to talk about.
Okay, so yesterday I had a nightmare.
But like, you're like, oh my god, Doki, are you okay?
But like, it's not type of, I told this nightmare to one of my friends.
And they're like, they laughed at me.
And I was like, no, you don't understand.
You don't under, in the moment, I was so sad.
You guys are like, gonna be like, oh no, I never tell you guys the story.
The nightmare, you guys gonna be like, Doki dot dot dot.
Okay, so this was the nightmare I had.
Like, I woke up, I was so fucking like, depressed when I woke up.
So, um, basically in my dream, I was in a, I was in a restaurant.
And I don't know, I think I was like in, I think like the time period was that I was like a university student and stuff.
So like, I was in a restaurant.
And they're like, and then like, you know, like the students are and I were like, oh, one of the students was like, we should get crepes.
And I was like, oh my god, I fucking want crepes so badly.
Yeah, we should get crepes.
And then, and then so like, the thing is, but the crepes is that when the crepes are starting to come out, we have to make it ourselves.
So we have to like, squirt the batter stuff ourselves and stuff like that.
But I didn't know how to do it.
I was like, oh my god, I don't know how to do this.
But there's a lot of people in this restaurant.
I was like, when it finally was my turn to get the crepes, they're like, you gotta do it yourself.
I was like, but I don't know how to do this.
So the staff came up and was like, don't worry, we'll do it for you.
And I was like, oh, that's great.
So I sat at the table and waited for the staff to make me my crepe.
And I waited.
And then the students, the other students were like, well, it's time to go now.
So I guess I'll see you guys.
See you later.
And I was like, okay.
And I kept waiting.
And I was like, where's my crepe?
And then so I went to the staff's like, hey, I'm still waiting for my crepe.
And they're like, oh my god, I'm so sorry.
We're gonna make your crepe.
So I was like, all right, cool.
And then I waited and I waited.
And then the staff came out and with my crepe.
And then they gave it to a person on a different table.
I was like, wait, that has to be my crepe.
There's no way.
I was like, no, no, that can't be it.
So now I waited.
And I waited.
And I saw the staff packing up and leaving the restaurant.
I was like, wait, who's gonna make my crepe for the restaurant?
I saw the staff just left.
I yelled and I was like, crepe.
And then they yelled back, we already made the crepe.
I was like, I was the one that ordered it.
And the most boring nightmare ever.
I was like, no way, I was the crepe.
Like, oh, sorry.
And then I guess we'll, don't worry, we'll send someone back.
I was like, okay.
So then I waited.
And then someone came, one of the staff members came back to the restaurant.
And like, all right, we're gonna make your crepe.
I was like, oh my god, thank you.
I waited for so long.
And then I woke up.
I was so sad, I was so sad.
I never got my crepe, guys.
I never got it.
I was doing so, it wasn't even, yes, you don't understand.
I never got my crepe.
You don't understand.
It was a nightmare.
I waited for so long.
I never got it.
This is nuts.
It was, it was a nightmare.
I was tempted by the, I saw so many other people with their crepes.
But I didn't even get my crepe.
It was a fucking nightmare.
I'm so sad.
I woke up so sad.
I was like, I never got it.
Everyone else around me got it.
And I never got mine.
This is more like a Seinfeld episode than a nightmare.
Mr. Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Julia Faye, worse than death.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Everyone, tell your crepe that you love them tonight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So that was my nightmare yesterday.
And then I was just so sad because I was like, I could have got it.
I could have got my crepe, but I never did.
There were so many instances where I could have got it.
I don't even know why I dreamt about it.
I guess I just ruined a crepe.
I never even ordered one, too.
I woke up from my nap and I never, I was just like, man.
I never got my crepe.
Anyway, time to grab some coffee.
Anyway, time to make some spaghetti.
I never even end up getting crepe in the end.
Anyway, that was my nightmare yesterday.
All right, Doki Amber Doge update.
So I found out that...
Okay, so like, I walked...
Okay, there's two updates.
There's two updates.
So last night, I walked him at midnight.
And like, it's really silly.
While I was walking him...
So obviously, there's like, no cars around.
Yeah?
So like, there's no cars around.
And so I was walking him and there was this one car that stopped at a red light.
And I was crossing the street.
And there's this guy.
He like, rolled down his window and then just shouted at me.
Hey, you have a cute dog!
And I was like...
Thank you!
I'm just like...
Okay.
I'm like, I'm pretty sure that guy's fucking high or some shit.
Because I'm Canada.
I'm like...
I'm just like...
Thank you!
I was just like...
And like, he shouted so loud.
I was like, it's midnight.
It's midnight and there's nobody here.
I felt so awkward because I'm like, I could hear you.
You don't have to shout.
It was so loud.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure he was like, he was not sober at all.
Because there was somebody like, in the passenger seat too.
So, cat calling?
No, dog calling.
Because like, I don't know what the fuck the driver was thinking.
Because it was like, some guy in the passenger seat that rolled down their window to shout that out at me.
So, that happened.
Another Doki Amber Doge update.
I found...
Okay, so...
I found something else that he fucking hates.
And no pretty woman can stop his hate for it.
So like, this is this morning.
I was waiting at the crosswalk.
And then, a pretty woman was next to me.
So then, Doki Amber Doge's dad was like, oh my god, she's so pretty.
And then, the thing is, she had rollerblades on.
But he didn't realize what they were.
So, he was like, oh my god, you're so pretty.
Can you like, touch me?
So, he like, walked up to her.
And then, so like, she ignored him.
Because like, I don't know, maybe she just doesn't like dogs.
And then, because usually, like, you know, when dad approaches women, they would like, try to pet him and stuff.
And then, dad would be like, yes, just as I foresee, I knew you would touch me.
But like, this time, this woman ignored him.
Because she was like, on her phone and stuff.
And then, so, but then, obviously, the crossing road turned, like, you know, you can cross the road.
It turned like, white.
Because it's like, a person.
And so, and then, she started rollerblading out.
And then, dad freaked the fuck out.
He was like, what is...
Like, he started barking at her.
Like, he wanted to chase her and started barking at her.
And was like, what is this, you fucking freak?
He's like, what is this?
Rollerblades?
What is on your feet, demon shoes?
He was like, oh my god.
He's like, what the fuck goes on your feet, you fucking freak?
Like, she just started rollerblading.
And he fucking freaked out.
And he was like, he was like, what are your...
What...
Demon shoes!
This is unnatural!
So, he was freaking the fuck out.
He wanted to, like, chase her down.
Had to, like, drag him.
I was just, like, pulling back on the leash.
I was like, no!
No, dad!
And she just rolled away.
And dad was so freaking out.
Because he's just like, oh my god.
I don't know what she is, but she is not real.
She is not real.
Curse you and your wheels.
She's a witch!
A murder!
But yeah, that's another...
That's another...
You got two dad updates today.
Um...
So, finally.
I still have a lot of things to talk about.
But I'm gonna fucking...
What's the word?
Space them out.
So, like, I have more content for other streams.
But I'll give you guys a Marvel Rivals, Twitch Rivals team update.
So, we finally got our sixth player.
It's very difficult because I actually, like, let the team pick the sixth player.
Because I was like, I don't know.
I actually really want to get top four.
So, I was like, you guys pick.
Here's, like, all the people that, like, sent...
Some of them even...
Some people even, like, DM'd me to, like, be like...
Oh, can I be on your team?
Like, here are my...
Here's, like, my trackers and everything.
Like, here's, like, uh, like, uh, what, like, my rank is, what I play.
So, the biggest issue was that a lot of people that wanted to join my team, um, was like...
Oh, uh, they shared the same hero pool as me.
So, like, they literally played the same things as me.
And there was no point in picking somebody up that played the same thing as me.
Because, like, because then, like, why I would be playing that role?
Like, because I'm the highest rank for support.
So, obviously, I'd be playing that role.
Um, so, like, why would you put the weaker player on the role that I'm the best at?
So, um, so, it was, like, Luna Snow.
And I'm actually really...
I finally unlocked my third eye and figured out how to play Cloak and Dagger.
Like, it was crazy.
I, like, I have, like, an 80% win rate on Cloak and Dagger now.
I actually unlocked my third eye.
I fucking finally figured it out.
Like, at first, I didn't understand, but now I understand.
But, like, so, but a lot of them played characters that I played.
So, like, you know, Luna Snow and Mantis is, like, the two characters I specialize in.
I can play any support, but I specialize in, like, Luna, Mantis, and Adam.
So, obviously, um, Cloak and Dagger is pretty easy.
Yes, but then you have to time her Cloak ability.
That was the thing I had the most trouble with.
It was, like, the DPS, the blinding.
I was really bad at blinding and, like, timing the, like, um, the Cloak ability.
For, like, enemy ults.
So, when Magneto ults, I have to be able to Cloak everybody at the right time.
So, like, that's what I struggled the most.
But I finally fucking opened my third eye this season.
Like, I, I did, I had a game.
I had, like, several games on Cloaks where I actually denied Strange ult and, like, and Magneto ult.
So, I was, like, so happy because I was, like, I finally did it.
I figured it out.
I unlocked it.
Like, I, I finally no more 30% win rate on Cloak and Dagger.
I had a 30% win rate on Cloak and Dagger last season.
But, like, this season, I finally did it.
I have an 80% win rate on Cloak and Dagger.
I fucking finally figuring it out.
I understand now.
Um, anyway, so.
So, so, like, obviously, there's a lot of people, there's a lot of support players in Plat or, like, Gold in Plat that were basically my same hero pool.
So, like, that, like, narrows it down a lot of, like, candidates.
And then, um, and apparently, uh, the, one of the members, one of the pro players was, like, messaging some of the people and just, like, giving them, like, it was sort of like a mini trial or something.
Like, giving, like, analyzing their, like, matches and, like, two of the players actually, like, got together in a call and was, like, also, I would never pick up a Rocky Raccoon player.
I don't, I fucking, I would never get over my prejudice against Rocket, Rocket.
I will never pick up a Rocky Raccoon player.
Anyway, so, especially their one chick on Rocket Raccoon.
So, like, two players got in a call.
Two of the pros got in a call and were, like, looking through account stats and, like, looking through, like, replays and, um, and, and, like, um, and, like, seeing, like, who would best fit, uh, who would best fit our team.
Cause I was like, I don't fucking know who to pick up.
I don't know.
So, um, also, in the end, we picked up a small timer.
Um, she was one of the few people that wanted to join.
She sent in, like, wanted to, uh, apply to, not, like, say apply, but, like, wanted to join, um, during my open call for teammates.
And, um, so her name is Sabubu.
And if you guys don't know who Sabubu is, she is actually an incredibly, apparently from what I'm told, she is an incredibly talented, uh, female player.
Um, she is, uh, she used, she was a top 100 deadlock player and was also a Valorant professional gamer for female teams.
And she's also, uh, really young.
I was like, man, I feel like shit.
I saw, I was like, wait, she's, she's how old?
And she was a top 100 deadlock player.
Don't, you can literally look up her username and see, like, she has a Liquipedia page, by the way.
She has a, she has a, she has a Liquipedia page.
And I was like, I don't have a fucking Liquipedia page.
I don't even have a Liquipedia page, guys.
Anyway, um, um, so yes, but she has never played Marvel Rivals before.
So, like, that's what I was really concerned about.
Um, but then she played one game on, she, then she, she has, like, and then she, like, was like, don't worry, I can learn really, really, really fast because she was top 100.
She was top 100 deadlock player.
And then deadlock is a third person, is a third person shooter.
So it's, like, pretty similar.
I can, I can, I can, the aim is sort of similar.
And she already has, she has hands, like, she, she has hands.
So she can, she can aim.
So that's good.
Um, and so she's been, like, hard grinding, uh, Marvel Rivals.
Uh, why do I, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, um, so she's hard grinding Marvel Rivals right now to, like, like, learn everything, learn, like, her role in time for Friday.
So that's the update.
We had a lot of people that really wanted to join.
It was so difficult.
I mean, I didn't have to make the choice because I was like, I didn't want to take responsibility.
So I was like, I recruited four of the other members.
It's your turn.
You recruit the last one because I don't fucking know.
I'm done.
So, so I was like, you guys handle the sixth member.
I don't fucking, I don't care anymore.
I did my job and then I had to, like, organize, um, but you're the captain.
That's why I made the open call, guys.
I made the open call for, I got the, I got the applicants in.
It was up to them to figure out.
Yeah, and I delegated, guys.
I thought you guys wanted me to delegate more.
I delegated it to my other teammates to figure out our last member.
So, and it was good because, like, so BooBoo was, uh, it was, um, was not up a plat because she didn't play, she didn't play Marvel Rivals season zero.
So that was great.
Um, you know what was funny?
I, I wrote in the recruitment post.
I was like, please, it has to be maximum plat.
And then I got people applying.
They're like, I'm GM.
I was like, I'm sorry, man.
But the application was already denied when you said I'm GM.
Well, we specifically told her, we're like, do not grind past plat.
That's what we told Kony, too.
Because Kony was like, oh yeah, I stopped that plat, um, just so I could get the rewards and ever sort of played more after that.
And I was like, do not get past plat.
Like, we need you at plat.
I was like, we need you in plat.
That you are, this is our only hope.
So we told both of our plat players that they have to, well, technically, so BooBoo is not in plat yet.
I think she's like almost at gold.
But like, she might get to plat.
And we're like, do not get past plat.
We, we need you to stay.
We need you to stay there.
So we actually, our team already got, like, ruled booked twice by other teams because our team is like one of the stronger teams.
I mean, like, yeah.
I mean, I think a lot of teams are going to complain about my team, for sure.
Because, like, my team is not made for, like, it's made to have fun.
But we want to win.
We want to get top four.
Like, we want to get top four.
So it's a lot of money, in general.
Like, for, it's a lot of money.
Like, apparently, it's like, it's like, if you win every match on day one, plus first place, each player gets around 5k each.
5k each.
So that's already a lot.
Because in the official Marvel Rivals tournament, um, in the official Marvel Rivals tournament, I think first place was, like, less than 1k for each player.
And it was longer, too.
It was, it was, like, in the span of, like, one, like, a month and a half.
And they had to, like, scrim and then, you know, go to games.
And it was literally, like, less than 1k for first and second place for each player.
I think, like, second place team got, like, I think, like, $500 for, like, second place.
And so, so, like, within Twitch Rivals, for two days, you can, we, at max, at max, you can get, like, um, around 5k maximum for first place and winning every match.
So I was like, guys, we got it.
Also, like, you know, my ego, too, so...
Also, because of my, you know, boosting my ego as well would be pretty nice, too.
Like, that's, like, the bonus for me.
For me, it's just ego.
For the other players, it might be for money.
Um,
so, so, um, so, yeah.
So we actually got rulebooked twice by different teams because my team, like, on paper, seems very not fair.
But I try, I, like, double check the rules to make sure, like, everything is fine.
Or the rulebook count.
So, like, one of the rules is that, um, we can only have two Overwatch pros.
For some reason, they don't count Marvel rival pros.
They're like, you can only have two maximum Overwatch pros, um, that's been a pro player for a year.
So, like, at most a year.
So if they've been a pro player within the last year, then it counts.
But thing is, I only have one player, technically, um, on my team that was a pro Overwatch player within the last year.
So, like, the other, the two other players, because I have three players that are in the, um, like, in, like, one of the best Marvel rival teams.
And, and, uh, uh, obviously, that doesn't count for some fucking reason.
So I was like, that's my loophole.
Like, I was like, I was like, that's my loophole because it's not in the rules that they can't be current Marvel rival pro players.
They just have, they just can't be Overwatch pros.
So, so, anyway, anyway, so I have, so, um, my tank player, Hogs, was apparently a coach for Overwatch, but, like, he wasn't a pro player.
He was a coach.
So one of the members, one of the teams tried to rule book us and was like, Hogs should be counted as a pro player because he was a coach in Overwatch 2 within the last year.
And I was like, okay, we got the maximum two players.
Like, it still doesn't matter.
I was like, doesn't matter.
I can have two because our third player was never pro.
He wasn't, like, Gomez never went professional.
So, in Overwatch, he was just, he was in team Columbia.
He was in team Columbia, but that was like two or three years ago.
So, so, so, like, that was past a year ago.
So, so, whoa, we still fit the requirement.
So, um, it doesn't count.
And, like, a World Cup team doesn't technically, doesn't count as a pro because he was just in, like, the World Cup team.
So, there was just, like, a, but, like, I found loopholes by getting baby and old people.
Yeah, definitely not rigged at all.
I just really wanted, I just want to do well, guys.
I really love Marvel Rivals, guys.
I basically, I am the loophole analyst.
I was like, that's why you gotta cover all your bases.
Cover all, I'm very surprised.
I mean, it's not my fault you got, like, 500 loopholes.
So, that's why I'm aiming for, um, I'm aiming for top four.
I hope we get top four.
I'll be really sad.
I mean, I'd be sad, but I also hope we have lots of fun.
Um, so, I'm very excited.
I'm really, really excited to, to play on Saturday and Sunday.
I should be, I should be a lawyer.
You need to hire Doki to write the rulebook.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, anyway, so, yeah, that's basically the Marvel Rivals team update.
So, like, we're planning on scrimming, actually scrimming against other teams.
I've actually hit up other captains for other teams.
So, I'm, we're planning on setting up, like, because we don't practice our chemistry and synergy with, um, the plat players.
So, like, with Coney and Sabubu.
So, like, I want to make sure that we are okay.
Coney's getting coached by our tank player now, right now.
Well, not now, like, later today.
So, um, our, our main tank, our other, our, our, like, top 500 pro tank player is coaching Coney tonight.
So, that won't be on stream, apparently.
I think they're doing, like, off-stream coaching.
Um, and, um, so, we're gonna make sure Coney can work with our other tank player.
And we're gonna be scrimming against other teams.
So, I actually hit up a couple captains to be like, hey, you want to, like, scrim against us?
Because, like, you know, I just want to make sure that our team knows how to play with each other and everything.
So, um, so, we're planning on scrimming against other teams before the tournament and stuff.
I feel like it's, I don't know.
I don't know if I'm taking it way too seriously or if it's actually gonna be this serious.
Like, like, you know what's funny?
Apparently, J3 already announced his team, but Brawl Pro is on J3's team.
Um, and I actually was thinking about getting Brawl Pro as the sixth player, but then I remember he was an Overwatch player.
I didn't realize he never got passed to Ma- I didn't realize he didn't get to Masters in Overwatch in the last year.
I thought he did, because he used to be GM in Overwatch.
So, like, I legitimately thought he was GM and I thought he at least got to Masters within the last year.
So, um, so I was like, um, but then he was like, why didn't you ask me?
I'm already on J3's team.
Because when I made the open call, he messaged me and was like, why didn't you ask me?
Um, I, like, now I'm on J3's team, but if you asked me, I would have joined your team.
And I was just like, oh, I didn't know.
I thought you were.
You told me you play Overwatch.
I see you play Overwatch.
I thought you were Masters.
I never see him stream Overwatch, like, within the last year.
And he used to be.
Anyway, so I told Kony, because I found out.
Bropo is one of their tanks on J3's team.
And I messaged Kony about that.
He hasn't replied back because he's, like, really busy.
Because he has both the Sage Arm Slam and the, um, and this tournament.
And I messaged Kony.
I was like, you're going to be fighting against Bropo.
You're going to do a tank 1v1.
Are you really going to let Bropo diff you?
Like, I'm going to be like, Kony, are you really going to let Bropo diff you on tank, Kony?
So, so, so I messaged Kony that.
I haven't got a reply back yet.
So, like, I hope that's, like, enough motivation.
For Kony to, like, fucking beat his ass.
I hope, I hope, I hope that motivates Kony to, like, work even harder.
Sorry, guys.
I just wanted to give you guys, like, a life, like, just an update on everything.
I realized the update was, like, 35 minutes long, guys.
I'm sorry.
So, I hope we get, guys, legitimately, I hope we get top 4, guys.
That's all I wanted.
That's all I want.
Because top 4, top 4 is, like, 2k for each team.
And, like, oh, wait, no.
Top 4 is 3k.
So, like, it's not that, it's, like, just 2k less, you know?
So, like, top 4 would be pretty good as well, you know?
It's out of, by the way, it's out of 12 teams.
So, um, so, like, there's a lot of teams that we're competing against.
Uh, but, yeah.
Anyway, that's life update.
There's a lot of other update stuff, but, like, I'll keep that for another time.
Um, Paladin Knight, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's team has all the hype, talent, big favorites to win.
What if this turns into a one-and-done team on day one, like, in sports?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I just, please, I just, at best, I just want to get top 4.
That's all.
I created, I got, I got a team, guys.
I went full Avengers mode.
I was like, this, I, I went full Avengers mode for this.
I assembled a team.
I got rulebooked, guys.
Um, Simple Minded, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's a sweaty try-hard confirmed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
They're definitely gonna amend the rules next time because of Doki.
It's on them, those suckers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, I, I can't help it if I see a loophole.
You know damn well I'm gonna abuse that shit.
Like, like, that's what, that's what loopholes are for.
You got, that's why you gotta be very clear with your rules, guys.
You know, where I will find a way to cheese it.
I'm a cheeser, we all know that.
And that's why I think a lot of teams really are, really don't like my team.
Because a lot of teams, they, they like the really try-hard, the really like scary teams.
The ones that I know, the ones that I do know, like from their roster.
Because like the staff, like when I was like grabbing my team, I asked the staff like, how sweaty are the other teams?
Like, how competitive are these other teams?
So I know who to grab, like who, like if I should go full try or not.
Um, so one of the things I noticed is that some teams, one of the teams are like super scary.
But then the two members are actually flat or gold.
Like, so I'm like, whoa, whoops.
So it really, really depends on the two flat and below players.
Um, to be fair, Cody's actually flat.
He just never got past, uh, he just never got past like flat because he stopped playing.
But like, I feel like he has a lot of potential to be really, really good at the game.
Doki, you!
So, so I was like, oh man, I'm pretty sure, uh, I'm pretty sure Cody has a potential to be really, really, really good at the game.
If he actually like plays and practice and like gets coached by Hogs.
Anyway, um, anyway, uh, finally, we're about to play the game, guys.
For real, it's game time.
It's, it's gaming time.
Okay, so we'll see, we'll see on day one how well we do.
And then I'll realize, after day one, I'll, I'll see how, after day one, I'll realize what, what's, what's it gonna be like.
So, top four, guys.
Top four is my, top four is like, uh, my ideal goal here.
I don't want to say first place because I don't want to put too much pressure on myself.
So top four, top four.
Um, all right, new game.
Um, but yeah, at 10 p.m., I'm gonna be streaming on Twitch tonight at 10 p.m.
And, um, and I'm gonna do like some Twitch Rivals practice with like some of my teammates.
Uh, all right, what is this?
Okay, so apparently, context-wise, uh, this game is, uh, this game is made by the Finns.
And then when I saw people commenting on my schedule, they're like, Oh, and my, my stream post, my stream tweet, people were like, She doesn't know that the Finns made a real simulator game.
Finland is about to show her what she's got.
Finland's gonna teach her something today.
So, I'm a little scared.
Um, I'm a little, little scared about this.
Do I need a picture?
How do I start the game?
Guys, first off, how the fuck do I start the game?
Okay, um, I'm gonna...
It is apparently very realistic.
Uh, oh, where's the enter name?
Here?
Oh, okay.
Okay, real.
Uh, oh, wait, okay.
Doki.
Real.
All right, real doki.
Okay, real doki.
All right, so they'll know.
All right, let's begin.
I couldn't tell, it's not that informative.
It's not, it's not that informative, guys.
It's a little hard to feel.
What the fuck is this hole?
Is this, am I being given birth right now?
And then God said, you will love cars.
Oh my God.
My gosh, oh my God, is that a foot?
Am
I...
Wait, wait.
Oh my God, wait.
Oh my God, no way.
Oh my God, oh
fuck.
Oh my...
I've been, I've been birthed.
I didn't think it was that.
I thought it was a joke.
Oh my God, happy birthday.
What, it was true.
Oh my God, no wonder I love real.
What, I'm so bored.
Real was born.
So real, happy birthday.
Guys, when is my birth, guys?
Real.
You are made real.
Happy birthday.
And that's why I love cars.
I was born in the car and I shall die in the car.
Apparently,
this game is really, it's like a couple years old but like it got out of early access recently.
Cause I saw like, I was like, wait, I've seen people play this game before but I don't really know what it's about because I never really watched it.
1976.
Damn, that's a long time.
It was made in 2016?
Holy shit, it's been in early access for fucking ever.
Rodrigo, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
NF, so when is the 65484KM stream?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is it... am I still gonna be driving?
When does it end?
When is this intro gonna end?
Like... hello?
Wait a minute, this... oh my god!
Oh!
Sorry, I didn't... I thought I was still watching an intro.
Oh my god, we could've been here forever and nobody said that.
I would legitimately just... wait.
Wait, this is a survival game?
Why do I... I thought I was just building a car.
Oh, wait.
Oh, she doesn't know.
I actually don't know.
Oh, she actually doesn't know.
I thought I was just driving a...
I thought I was supposed to make a car.
What do you mean?
Wait a minute.
Okay, contrast, car mirrors.
Show... I don't need to show FPS, but my sensitivity for this game is so high that I can't adjust it.
Oh, wait.
I didn't realize.
What?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is Quaremus?
Oh, he's Garfield!
Oh, this is my room.
This is definitely my room.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki didn't have to get spanked by a doctor because Doki died in Apollo.
Let's go.
Thank you for the super chat, Wings.
Thank you, thank you.
This is definitely my home.
Where's my car?
Oh, there's my car!
Oh, am I rebuilding my childhood car?
That shouldn't be too bad.
If it's like... if it's like my old car.
Alright.
How do I... build it, though?
Dashboard meter.
Browse parts catalog.
Alright.
Why is this all in Finnish?
How the fuck am I supposed to read this?
What the fuck does...
Do I not have an English?
Am I supposed to know what that means?
Because you're in...
Yeah, but they should gear it towards me, a Canadian!
I'm an NA!
You know how like when Americans visit like places in other countries?
And then they be like, why aren't they catering towards me, an American, speaking English?
Why don't they speak English in this country?
Why don't they speak English in Finland?
How will I understand?
How am I supposed to understand if they do not speak English?
You do not want my American dollars?
Oh shit, I can drink?
What's this?
My notepad.
What if I want to drink, though?
Don't you mean that?
You're right.
My soon-to-be American dollars?
You're so right.
Oh, okay.
I don't think I need any food yet.
I'm not hungry yet.
Alright, let's figure out how to...
Oh, F is to interact?
Ooh, you know what I'm gonna do.
It's not building a car if you don't drink on the job.
Guys.
True American experience in Finland.
Getting drunk to build my fucking engine.
Wait, what's this?
Alright.
Alright, so true.
So fucking true.
Alright, how do I build an engine?
Oh, I'm feeling a little drunk.
Okay, do I have, like, any instructions on how to build it?
Is there...
Is there any instructions at all?
Or am I...
Am I potentially fucked?
No.
Alright, let's figure it out.
Can't be that hard, right?
Building an engine?
Alright, how do I piece things together?
Radio, electric...
How do I piece things together, though?
We rawdog it?
Okay, we rawdog it.
Alright, what if I just put this here?
That looks like it belongs in a car, right?
Is that how you do it?
Do I just, like, chuck it in like that?
Is that an engine part right here?
What is this?
What is this over here?
Radiator... Oh, I know what a radiator is!
That belongs in a car!
That's part of the engine!
I just... That's all I have to do, right?
The radiator is part of the engine too, right?
No, no, we'll be fine.
Oh, there it is!
That's an engine!
I know what an engine looks like!
That's an engine right here!
Alright, and then we put you in.
Okay, there we go.
We're cooking.
Alright, that's the engine block.
Okay, so like...
There it is.
And then...
Alright, let's get the radiator out.
I don't know if I'm supposed to just... I don't know if it, like, auto...
I feel like it doesn't auto let me pick it.
Oh no, now it's stuck.
Okay.
No, no, no, no!
Okay, so there's stuff that has to fit...
It has to be this, right?
The rocker shaft?
Or like... No, no, no, because there's holes in there!
So it has to be... The piston!
Yes!
That's right!
Alright, how do I rotate this?
Alright, so...
The piston obviously has to go in here.
But how do I put this in here?
Because that fits!
The circle block fits into the...
Fits into the circle hole.
Right?
That's what it's for!
It's circular!
That's what holes are for!
Okay.
Okay, it's not...
Wait, it's piston hole number 2.
Does that mean it goes in number 2?
Maybe it just goes in the second hole.
Maybe.
The circle block fits in the circle hole.
Okay, not that hole.
Maybe it's this one?
Nope.
Okay, it's rejecting it.
It's rejecting it.
Okay.
And then...
What does it connect to?
Like, how do I connect this to this?
Oh my god.
Wait, actually...
Maybe if I can... Okay, I need to grab this.
How do I grab this part of the car?
We're gonna figure this out, guys!
I can build a car!
I just need to figure out how to get rid of these item stacks and put in here.
Okay, let me...
Put this here.
Guys, this game is not very intuitive.
Alright.
So...
Now that I have my engine block...
I put you in.
Wherever an engine's supposed to go.
Oh, I have to use the bench?
A floor can... Oh my god, we don't need a fucking table.
Why do we need a table when we can use the floor?
A floor is just a table with no legs.
Like, it's just a waste of time.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, and then we gotta rotate...
How the fuck do I rotate this?
Oh my god.
How come I can only rotate...
Why can I only rotate it to the side?
Oh my god, please.
How do I rotate it other way?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I just have to keep dropping it.
Um...
There.
Why is you not piecing together?
You're a circle and you're a circle!
You're meant to be!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's upside down?
Oh, that makes so much more sense.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, nice.
I knew it.
I knew the circle block would match the circle.
Cause what else could it be?
Alright, and then...
Oh my god, how do I...
How do I rotate you any other way?
Ow!
Okay, there we go.
The circle hole goes into the circle.
Please go into the hole.
This is where you're meant to be.
There we go.
Alright.
What the fuck is a crankshaft?
Fuel pump, header, start...
The fuck?
Okay, radio, hubcap...
Clock gauge, oil filter...
Rocket shaft...
Drive gear...
Clutch...
Who the fuck cares?
The order never matters anyway, right?
Nobody...
Nobody cares about the order of this...
Fucking...
Building of an engine.
Everything would always work out in the end.
Alright, let's see...
Radio...
Nobody cares.
If people care about the order of how to build an engine...
Why do we have so many cars?
How do I rotate this?
How do I fucking rotate this?
I can only rotate this one way.
I can't...
Okay, if I chuck it...
Maybe it'll fall in a way.
Good point.
Alright...
If we care about the order...
Then why do...
Why does only Elon Musk's car explode?
Huh?
That's so fucked.
Did you guys hear about how like...
What's the car?
The really ugly looking one?
The Cybertruck?
Yeah, people were like...
People were like...
Oh yeah, it does that sometimes.
I was like, what do you mean?
The Cybertruck just explodes sometimes.
Like, what?
I don't think that's...
I don't think that's like...
I don't think cars are supposed to explode.
Like, yeah, they're like...
No, people are like...
No, people are...
The Cybertruck actually has...
Has like...
It's apparently...
There is a case where the Cybertruck could potentially explode.
I was like, what?
Like...
I know like now people are like...
Oh yeah, but that one was rigged to explode.
But at first, people were like...
Not surprised that it exploded?
And I was like...
What do you mean you're not surprised?
And they're like, oh, it's a Cybertruck.
Apparently, they're known to explode.
But I was like, what?
That...
When I...
When I go buy a car...
I'm not...
I don't think I'm looking for a car that explodes.
Oh wait, that's a crankshaft!
There it is!
But where does a crankshaft go?
Here?
Oh no!
It's ruined!
Where is it supposed to go?
That's a feature.
That shouldn't be...
How do I put this in you?
Like, is this in you, sir?
Is this inside you right now?
Oh wait, wait, wait!
It should be at the bottom!
Wait, I got it.
It should be on top of this, and then...
But like, how do I...
piece it together?
It should be on the bottom.
Why don't you go inside?
I don't understand.
Oh man, you guys were made for each other!
Please!
I will make this an arranged marriage if I have to.
And then you will be forced to love each other via time.
Okay.
Let's see.
This should be...
Okay, I'm going to put it upside down.
And then I'm going to force this marriage upon you.
Oh, there you go!
Yay!
See?
They'll eventually love each other.
There you go.
I told you guys.
See?
They were meant to be together.
I knew it.
Okay.
Guys, I need to figure out how to rotate this.
Rotate objects.
That does not help at all.
How do I...
Oh wait, I can...
Wait, I can urinate?
I can urinate.
I can smoke.
Lean right.
Drive.
What the fuck?
Oh, I don't have cigarettes.
I feel like I might need to pee though.
Alright, that's okay.
Wait, I should water the grass.
There we go.
Alright, hydrate my fellow grass.
Don't worry.
I watered the garden.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, we got this.
How do I fucking rotate this better?
I'm so fucking...
Okay.
Like, it won't let me fucking...
Okay, it's fine.
I'm calm.
Alright.
Okay, now that I got...
Maybe the rocket shaft?
That sounds like something for an engine, right?
No?
Okay.
It's not this.
Is it N?
Oh.
Okay.
Instead, I just called it a pussy.
Oh, there we go!
I did it!
Wait, what?
It was...
Wait, what the fuck?
It gave me a check mark...
and then it didn't piece together.
Oh, no.
Why can't you...
How do I...
Please...
How do you...
How do I put you together?
You're meant to be!
These are your kids!
No, and then I took it!
You can take it out!
Okay.
There we go.
I put it back in.
And then...
Oh, my God.
How the fuck get in?
How do I rotate it better?
Oh, my God.
It only lets me...
Why does it only let me rotate one way?
Why do you only let me rotate one way?
There has to be another rotation.
There has to be another way to rotate.
I refuse to believe...
That there's only one rotate.
There's no fucking way.
Where are the other rotations?
I'm crashing out.
I'm gonna crash out.
It's not even been like...
I feel like it's not even been 10 minutes on this stupid fucking car.
I'm gonna crash out.
I am using my middle mouse button.
But it only lets me rotate...
Up and down.
Where's the sideways?
Where's the...
Oh, my God.
I'm leaning in.
I'm gonna pass out.
Let me try turning it on and off again.
No, I don't need a tutorial.
I'm gonna make an engine.
It's the last thing I do.
I don't need a tutorial.
I can do this.
I can make a fucking car.
How hard can it be?
You don't need degrees for this.
I'm gonna force my way into a car.
I was born in a car.
I was made to have a car.
Oh, yeah, water pump.
I was born and I shall die in a fucking car.
Okay.
Got this.
I feel like there's so many holes for no reason.
Let me grab...
Like, what am I supposed to do with a spinner set?
The fuck is up bearings?
Battery, radiator, hose, inspecting, gearbox, rocker shaft, clutch, clutch plate, engine plate, drive gear, shatter, headers, fuel pump, water pump.
Oh, that's a bearing?
Okay.
Chat makes a car.
This is today's stream.
Okay, where does the bearing go?
Does the bearing go in a hole?
Where is it supposed to go?
Does it go into the hole?
Or does it go here?
Is this where it goes?
I wish...
I wish I can rotate this any other way.
I...
I wish I can...
Does it go into the...
Does it go onto this?
Why don't you go in?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
That's where you go in.
Told you, you would love each other eventually.
I knew you would love each other.
Okay, now I should be able to put this in.
Right?
Are you serious?
I have to bolt it in place?
It's already fucking...
connected.
Am I bolting?
Is this how you use tools?
Bolt together.
I demand you to get in.
I...
Now kiss.
Now...
I...
I demand you to fit together.
Did I do it?
What did I do?
What the fuck is two?
Oh, it's car tool mode.
How do I use my car tools?
Am I using it?
Am I?
Oh!
Is it this one?
I don't know which size it is.
Is it a tiny size?
Is it size three?
Is it size four?
Oh, it's size four.
No?
Size five?
How small are you?
Oh my god.
Are you smaller?
Do you need a little small wrench, little guy?
Okay, it's size four, but like...
Oh, it's even smaller?
Do you feel...
Oh!
Oh no!
I'm trying to figure this out as soon as you guys!
Wait, I need one more bearing?
Where the fuck is this third bearing supposed to go?
Oh, here.
Okay.
It was this size, it was the fourth one.
No, it was the smaller.
Wait, what?
It's smaller?
What size was it?
Okay.
This is not intuitive right now at all.
Finnish people, how the...
Do you like fun?
Are you...
Is seasonal depression that bad that this is fun?
Is the lack of...
Did the lack of sun fuck you up?
How...
This is fun.
Is this what happens when you don't see the sun 90% of your life?
Like, I don't understand.
I'm Finnish.
I'm sorry.
This is fun in Finland.
The urge to build an engine with no rule, nothing to help you.
How do I figure this?
How am I supposed to figure this out on my own?
I don't understand.
Why is screwing in the screws a fucking scroll wheel?
Why the fuck is it scroll wheel?
This is where the fun begins.
It's like 99% of the population in Finland fucking engineers?
Are you guys all mechanics?
What is this?
You can't graduate university until you build your own fucking car?
That's the magic of this game.
We are the happiest country in the world.
FYI.
Oh my god.
The simple things make you happy.
Yes.
Every Finnish people is born in a fucking car.
Apparently.
Okay.
Now that we got the whatever fucking bungles in.
Now I should be able to fit this.
Oh my god.
Fucking finally.
The circle hole can finally go into the circle.
Whenever I figure this out.
There we go.
Oh my god.
It can finally go into the circle hole.
Thank god I figured it out.
I did it.
I'm almost like 1% Finnish now.
At this point.
If you fucking complete an engine, you become Finnish.
Okay.
Come on.
Go in the hole.
How?
Oh my god.
I'm crashing.
I don't understand why I can only rotate it in one direction.
I should be allowed.
You made a very detailed car building simulator.
But you can't rotate an item left and right.
I don't understand.
How do you have all these fucking parts?
A fucking water pump.
A water pump pulley.
A fucking carbonator.
But you can't rotate an item left or right.
How?
Like, I feel like this was the most simple thing to add in the rule.
I don't want much.
I just want to be able to rotate left or right.
That's all I asked for.
Like, left or right.
Not just up or down.
Tiny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why mechanics charge so much.
They spend years learning how to rotate parts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're only finished when you get the car.
If you cannot make your own car, you're fucking you get deported from the country.
Like, whenever a Finnish person hits the age of 18, they are required to go through the mandatory government test, where you have to build a car, and if you don't build a car, you're deported to Sweden.
Damn, she gets it now.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's getting a taste of the car building experience.
Anchor, also second first super chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, thank you for the very first super chat.
Doki, you think this is bad?
Just wait till you tune the engine, or when something breaks you need to take the- I HAVE TO TAKE THIS APART?!
FUCKING PUT THREE PIECES TOGETHER!
Like, what are you- It took me 30 minutes!
IT TOOK ME 10 MINUTES TO ROTATE ONE ITEM!
WHAT DO YOU MEAN I HAVE TO TAKE THIS APART?!
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright.
Pretty sure the pet gasket has to go on top of this, right?
It's the same shape.
Yeah, alright.
That sounds right.
It's the same shape.
It looks the same.
It should be good.
Okay, and then... I have- I don't know.
I just thought, like, same shape.
So it should be...
It should be the same.
Okay.
I got this.
Okay, I know hubcaps are for the wheels.
Alright.
Distributor.
Uh...
Water pump.
Oil pan.
Cylinder head.
The fuck does all of this mean?
Does the rocket shaft go in here?
Is that what it's for?
There are also holes.
There are still holes here.
What do you mean I have to bolt more stuff down?
What the fuck do you mean by that?
It's- Oh my god, no.
Don't listen to them.
They don't know what- Not all of them are finished.
They could be fucking with you.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
Now I should be bolting things down, right?
That should be, right?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll find the screwdriver.
The spanner or whatever the fuck that screwdriver was.
This is the wrench.
The wrench that will fit this.
Right?
There's a wrench that fits this, right?
Oh my god.
This is why I Uber.
This is exactly why I Uber.
Ah, fuck it.
Nothing needs to be screwed down forever.
If I have to take it apart, I don't- If I never- If I have to take it apart, what's the point of screwing things down?
Okay.
Alright.
Now, now I should be able to screw things down, right?
No?
So true.
That's all I'm saying.
Like, what's the point- Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Is that down?
Should be it.
Okay, now I can't break apart.
I did it.
Okay, I did it.
My god, I fucking finally did it.
I'm gonna build my own- Can I die?
Wait a minute.
I'm just like thinking, what if I just fucking not eat?
Oh my god, this is actual hell.
I can actually die.
Should I have used a 3D model?
You want to rotate?
David, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jake, thank you for the super chat.
I can watch GTA Pro tags steal cars down to avoid this.
Thank you for the super chat, Jake.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus, thank you for the super chat.
Pro finish strategy.
Don't screw everything down so the engine can disassemble itself for you.
Exactly!
What's the point of screwing everything down?
We're gonna take it apart anyway.
Like, it's a waste of time.
The car- The hood of the car can keep everything together.
If we stuff the entire engine area, the hood of the car, with everything, nothing can come apart because it's all like clumped up together.
How can- How can it come apart if everything's squished together?
Alright.
How am I stressed?
How are you stressed out?
I say as I scream at him.
How- What?
You don't need to go to school.
You're just building a car.
You're just building a fucking car.
How are you stressed out?
You don't have to do anything else.
I bet you live with your parents.
How are you stressed out?
You live- You barely have Garfield in your- You do not live alone.
You don't have to pay bills.
You don't- All you do in your life is build a fucking car.
That's all.
How are you stressed?
Doki said calmly.
You live with your parents.
You have zero bills to pay.
How the fuck are you stressed out?
Doki, please.
Doki asked calmly.
Calmly.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay.
That should be everything.
And then...
Okay.
What else?
Gearbox.
Linkage.
Battery.
Radiator.
Hose.
The fuck is next?
On my car?
Does this cover it?
Oh, okay.
I did it.
Did I finish my engine?
Wait, guys, did I just finish my engine?
Is that it?
Okay, let me make sure there's nothing else.
There's more to this, but there's nothing else I could put on it!
Requiring mass.
Uh...
Oh my god, that's not good.
If a speedrun is more than 10 minutes, that's when you know I'm in for a fucking wild ride.
The fuck?
What else does this need?
What more do you want from me?
Oh my god.
What's gonna happen to my fridge?
Oh, there's no way this simulator has...
There's no way this simulator makes it so that my electricity bill goes up by... I can't even close the fridge.
My electricity bill goes up.
Don't be lazy.
Fix your old...
Dad's old car.
Don't drink alcohol.
We will come back with...
We can't pour it.
Whoops.
Um...
Okay, gotta hide the...
I gotta hide the evidence.
Uh...
Why have a sauna?
How fucking rich am I?
I do live in the middle of the woods.
So...
What the fuck?
Okay, mom and pops won't know that I drink beer.
Am I over 18?
Okay.
No, I should be.
I'm doing my mandatory government...
You know how, like, in...
Korea, you have to enlist in the army at age 18?
In Finland, you gotta take your mandatory car building test.
And if you...
Like I said, if you don't make it, you get deported to Sweden.
Like...
Alright.
So it's just like that.
Alright, let's see.
We're real Finland.
Okay.
What else does this need?
I don't understand.
An oil filter?
What do you want from me?
Like, what do you want from me?
You're just a block!
Oh my god, like, I don't understand.
What parts fit this?
What the fuck is a carburetor?
Okay.
Do you fit?
Oh my god.
Water pump pulley?
Okay, maybe if I...
Oh my god, what if I just do it like the puzzle way?
I'll start mashing parts together, and then...
Oh my god, I knew it.
I'm gonna do it the puzzle way.
I just start mashing random parts together and see if something works.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're so smart, Doki.
Just start mashing things together and something will start to fit.
Oh my god, I knew it.
The order never matters.
If the order matters, why didn't they give me instructions?
Don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
It just works.
Okay, I just need to...
I'm a genius at work.
It's just like making a puzzle.
You start putting things together until things piece together.
Okay, so obviously a radio will need...
A radio would need wires, right?
So like... Oh, what the fuck am I gonna do with a fuel pump?
The fuck is a gearbox?
What goes in the goddamn fucking gearbox?
Does this go in?
No.
Um...
Okay, maybe something... A distributor?
Do you go together?
Oh my god, what does it do?
What does it do?
Do you piece together?
Gears?
Oh my god, you're so right.
Maybe if I... Oh my god, the engine plate!
This is the engine.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We got one of the engine plates on.
I don't know where the other is supposed to go, but that's alright.
The timing cover?
For what?
Oh!
I can put the gear stick on right now.
But where's the...
Okay, wait.
Can I?
There we go.
I told you, it's just like a puzzle!
I can put it in!
There we go!
I fucking knew it!
Oh my god!
I knew it.
I could just put it on right now.
There we go.
I'm so smart.
The gear stick goes in.
I know where gear sticks go to.
Thank you for the very first super chat!
Thank you!
I am a journeyman mechanic with over 12 years experience.
And I'm incredibly amused and also in physical pain watching you try to assemble this engine.
You can do it.
I believe in you.
See!
They think I can make a...
I told you guys, I knew I was a genius all along.
If a mechanic says I can fucking do it, then I can do this.
I'm told I'm naturally talented in everything I do.
Including building an engine.
Okay.
Now I'm a little stuck right now.
I'm thirsty.
I gotta drink some water.
Is my family never coming home?
How do I drink water?
Do I have cups?
What the fuck am I...
Why can't I...
Am I not allowed to open...
Do I have...
This entire area just like...
Did they just child-proof the entire area that I'm just not allowed to drink anymore?
Like...
How do I close the fridge?
Let me close!
I can't!
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
Oh, I have to lean forward?
Okay, how do I lean forward?
Lean right.
Lean forward.
E.
Please, let me lean forward.
Am I drinking?
Alright, I just...
I guess I just...
I'm not allowed to have a cup until I build this car, I guess.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need to water the plants real quick.
There you go.
I hope you grow up big and strong for daddy.
You big boy, grow up to be a strong tree, little man.
The fitness way.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
How am I still stressed out?
I don't understand.
I'm perfectly calm right now.
Realistic?
It's a fucking real ass simulator.
Okay.
Carburetor.
Where would a carburetor go?
Where the fuck is a carburetor?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that it?
Is that everything an engine needs?
Did I do it?
I think I did it.
That's everything an engine needs.
Do you think it got in?
Do you think it's in, guys?
Do you think I can drive my car with this now?
It doesn't look right.
It's all covered up.
Oh, just because it's a little dirty, it doesn't look right.
Well, an engine is like...
An engine is an engine, okay, guys?
It doesn't matter what it looks on the outside.
It's all about what's on the inside, and I bet you the inside looks amazing.
What the fuck?
Drive gear.
Timing cover.
Starter.
Electric master cylinder.
The fuck are all these?
I feel like they just made up some of these words.
At this point, some of these words seem made up.
I don't know if they're real or not.
If it's missing some stuff, why can't I fit it in?
Huh?
If it truly is missing things, then why can't I fit it into this engine?
Huh, guys?
Checkmate.
Nothing fits.
Okay, maybe...
Oh!
I did it!
Brute force, let's go!
Until I see...
Oh my god.
There's another gear.
Where did it...
Where does this one go?
Where is it going to?
I don't know.
It's trying to fit somewhere, but it doesn't know where.
Liz, I know you're supposed to fit!
Oh no.
Wait, maybe this...
Is this?
It's not?
Okay, maybe it's this.
Because they're both clutches.
Oh my god, please.
There we go.
No?
I did it.
It should fit now.
Yes, I did it!
I'm a fucking genius.
That's how you know you want your car.
You prove...
That's when you know it's a good engine.
When a mechanic makes a puzzle out of it.
That's when you know.
Oh no.
Don't you love it when your mechanic was like, does it fit?
If it doesn't fit, it doesn't work.
Wait, clutch master.
Shouldn't that be over here?
Is there both clutches?
Is that not it?
If it's not clutches, where would it go?
Exactly, if it doesn't fit, it wasn't meant to be.
Wait.
Oh my god, I did it.
Wait, it got off.
Wait, what?
Wait, why isn't it fitting again?
How does it just break apart?
It can do that?
But
I thought you guys fit.
You can just break apart like that?
Oh my god.
Why don't you fit?
Did you guys got in a fight?
Please don't get a divorce.
I'll be so sad.
Oh my god.
If I use Gorilla Glue on an engine, do you think it'll explode?
Cause like, what's the difference between Gorilla Glue and bolting it down?
Are they both like, you know...
Toki, no.
Has anyone tried that?
You know, using Gorilla Glue versus like, bolting...
Okay, I'm padding a bed.
Fuck this.
Mom and dad can come home and clean up for me.
Where are my cigarettes?
Like, how am I supposed to like, de-stress?
Wait, why was I like...
Oh, yeah.
It's like, oh, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait.
I don't like that.
What?
Wake up.
Hello?
Wait, why is it so dark?
Wait.
Is it midnight?
But it's Tuesday.
Wait a minute, where am I supposed to go?
Wait a minute.
I forgot.
Because it's Finland, the sun sets down the sun sets down faster.
I forgot about that.
Oh, no, I'm gonna die of stress before the sun comes back out.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot you guys only get sunlight for two hours a day.
Might as well.
Not in summer, the sun doesn't go down.
I don't know, it feels like winter right now.
Like, do I just not have windows?
Like, do I?
Where the fuck is my window?
Like, would it be illuminated by the fucking stars?
It's like, do stars not exist in Finland?
Dude, they just decided to be like, fuck Finland, there's no stars, I guess.
Who needs windows?
It's cloudy, oh yeah.
Today of all days, it's cloudy.
Oh my god.
Please, where's the light?
Where am I?
Oh, wait.
There's my poster.
Oh my god.
See my poster.
Can I sleep again?
Wait.
There's my poster.
There's the wall.
What's this?
Is this the light?
Oh.
Is this my door?
Where's the light?
Where the fuck is the light?
Oh no, I don't think I'm ever...
Oh my god, I found it!
The fuck are the stars?
Where's the stars in Finland?
Alright, now...
I gotta figure out this area.
Okay, we gotta take a shower.
Alright.
Where's the shower area?
Can I use my parents' shower?
I couldn't leave Finland.
Okay, where's...
Okay, that's the outside.
And then I gotta figure out where the shower...
Okay, the shower was right here.
Alright.
And it was like right here.
I gotta wear stuff.
No, that's the closet.
Okay, it's right here.
There we go.
And then...
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna take a shower.
Hello?
Please, I'm...
Please, help.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Now I'm clean.
I'm a clean boy.
I'm a clean boy, guys.
There we go.
I'm so clean.
Alright, now that's over.
Yeah, that's my mandatory shower stream of the year so that my channel doesn't die.
I did it.
I saved my channel.
Wait, maybe there's cigarettes in my parents' room.
Alright.
That's all we get.
There's my clickbait for the year.
I can see the clippers right now.
Don't keep her tick shower on stream?
In front of...
In front of everybody?
Oh my God.
Wait, but where's my...
How am I gonna get less stressed out?
I don't understand.
Man.
Where the fuck is my...
cigarettes?
Oh, I don't like this.
I hear like flies everywhere.
Oh, does drinking release stress level?
You liars.
It just makes me wanna pee.
At the buy smokes?
It's midnight!
Okay, let me...
Wait, the sauna?
The sauna helps too?
Okay.
Alright, I'm learning more and more about Finland as we play.
Alright.
Sauna time.
How do I do this?
Oh, oh!
I know how to use the sauna.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta figure out how to fucking flip a bucket again.
There we go.
Alright.
Filling up the bucket.
Does it work if I pee in it?
Let's try.
I have some pee in me.
Wait, did I...
Oh my god.
Okay, no, the water...
Things just don't exist in Finland too, which makes sense.
Alright, let's see.
No, it doesn't, guys.
I can't stop.
Oh, don't worry.
I can stop.
Okay.
No, okay, I cannot.
Sorry, I couldn't hold it in.
How do I...
Go in.
What the fuck?
Go in!
How do I miss it?
Please, I'm gonna die of stress!
I have to turn a saun... Okay, wait, wait.
How do I turn the sauna on?
Okay, now it's less of a make your car simulator.
And it's like figuring out...
Oh, there it is.
Please.
Okay.
Does that work?
Now what?
Am I still stressed out?
Is this it?
I need a spoon?
Oh, shit.
I don't want my mom to yell at me.
I should turn that down.
I don't want the wire bills to go up.
Where the fuck is the spoon?
Is the spoon in the kitchen?
It's on the bench?
Okay.
I can barely see.
It's so fucking dark.
Alright, where is my spoon?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I see it.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay.
Can I use a spoon?
The first test of the day.
Can I...
Alright.
Did it work?
Why isn't it working?
Oh.
Oh, it's left.
Can I get right click?
Why is it not working?
The temperature in the wall?
What's the temperature?
Okay, it's at 20 degrees.
Okay, we gotta turn the temperature up.
Is that high?
No, that's...
Did I turn it off?
I don't think it's going up.
Oh, I turned it off.
Okay.
I can't tell.
Two of the knobs, they look the same.
Please.
I need it to go up.
Oh, wait.
It's a dick.
Okay.
Why is it still there?
Why is my dick still at 30 degrees?
What?
Guys, don't you hate it when your dick is only 30 degrees?
Don't you hate it when that happens?
First world problems.
Yeah, it's pretty annoying.
Yeah.
God.
That's the worst, guys.
It has to be at least 100 degrees every day.
It's not even going up.
It's just stuck at 20 degrees.
I've never had such problems.
Isn't that it?
The stress.
Oh my god.
I swear.
I'm going to die of stress before I fucking make my car.
It doesn't even go up.
Why don't you go up?
Why you don't go up?
I don't understand.
Alright, I'm going to let it warm up for a little bit.
Sometimes we have difficulty.
It takes time, donkey.
Where is this fly?
Oh my god, this fly is actually driving me insane.
I have no idea where this fly is.
Like, does TV make me less stressed?
Like, I'll do anything to be less stressed out.
Oh my god, I can't even turn on the TV.
I'm fucking stupid.
Oh my god, I'm going to fail my car building exam.
And then I'm going to get deported to Sweden!
Or even worse, Denmark.
I'm joking, please.
I'm sorry.
I need Denmark goons.
I don't mean it.
I'm just roleplaying as a Finn.
I'm just...
We all know you Scandinavians hate each other.
We all know...
No!
We all know you Scandinavians hate...
You think...
You Scandinavians think you're the better Scandinavian country.
It's like Viking hatred now.
Alright, let's see.
Take her to Ikea.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Spencer, thank you for the super chat.
Alright.
Oh my god, how do I...
Am I...
Why am I getting less stressed out?
There's nothing to watch.
And I'm gonna die from stress.
Oh my god.
Where do I go?
Is the sauna ready?
Do you think it's ready now?
Oh my god, do you think it's ready?
Is my sauna ready?
Hello?
Oh my god, it has 40 degrees.
Oh my god, it's working.
Oh yeah, I forgot about the audio setting.
I'm sorry, sound guy.
I forgot we had to...
It's been an hour and 43 minutes and I forgot about the audio.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god, I feel...
I'm still just as stressed out.
I don't even know if it's working.
Oh my god, it's going to 40 degrees.
It's coming up, guys.
And I'm so fucking stressed out.
Okay.
Alright.
Is it okay?
Oh, I'm getting less stressed.
I'm doing it.
It's working.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god, it's so slow, though.
It's almost daytime.
It's actually almost daytime.
I'm doing it.
I'm becoming more and more finished.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can see the clickbait.
Doki only showers once a year.
Okay.
I need to be on the bench.
How the fuck do I sit down?
Oh my god, the birds are chirping.
The sun is shining.
And you are going to have a bad time.
This is the viking way.
Am I sitting down?
I don't know if I've learned how to sit down yet.
There's so many things I haven't learned.
I couldn't make a trip.
How far is the store for cigarettes?
Because I don't think I can do this again.
I'm having a bad time.
There's going to be a...
I can burn my house down?
Wait, what?
Okay, let me turn this down.
What do you mean I can burn my house down?
Hold on.
Oh no, my parents are not going to like that.
I don't think my parents would like if I burn my house down.
Okay, we gotta get a bike and buy some...
Oh, you know what?
I can just steal the sauna, honestly.
I can't be bothered to fucking ride my bike.
Wait, where did I put this here?
I legitimately can't be bothered.
Okay.
Alright.
I was trying to figure out how to piece these two together.
Why won't it go together?
It worked before.
I don't understand.
It was together before.
Okay.
I don't have any more bolts.
Can I unbolt it?
Maybe if I unbolt it.
I'll try the small one first.
Okay, not that.
Not that.
I don't need...
Instructions are for pussies.
A real mechanic does it all by feel.
If you're a real mechanic, you like close your eyes, and you go into your mind palace, and everything just comes together in your mind.
If you can't do that, you're a fucking failure of a mechanic.
As every mechanic will tell you, if you can't see it in mechanic vision, then you were never meant to be a mechanic.
It's true.
Please never touch a car.
It's like the Terminator vision.
But for mechanics, you know?
You just see all the squares and the little buttons and everything.
You don't see that, guys.
Oh, I guess you were never meant to be a mechanic.
It really sucks that that's how you find out.
You're not in the right profession.
You need to be born...
It's not like a skill you can just get better at.
You gotta be born with it, guys.
If you're not born with it, you might as well quit while you're in.
You might as well quit because you're a fucking failure.
I can't confirm that mechanic vision is a thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You gotta be born with the mechanic vision.
It's not a fucking skill, it's a talent.
Yeah, exactly.
Every mechanic was born in a car and will die in a car.
If you were not born in a car, you might as well quit right now in mechanic school.
There shouldn't even be a mechanic school.
Mechanic school is like a scam.
A real mechanic doesn't need to go to school to become a mechanic.
Wait, there's more stuff here?
What the fuck is this?
The real mechanics are born.
Fuel tank, car check.
Yeah, they're not made, they're born.
What else does this engine need?
I need a...
I can't...
It won't let me attach it!
I don't understand.
I just don't understand.
Why can't I attach anything?
There's no more bolts in here!
What other bolts do I have?
What, the entire engine?
Where?
It won't let me tighten anything.
Sorry, my mechanic vision is acting up right now.
I'm only struggling because I already used my cooldown on my mechanic vision, guys.
Any mechanics wanna help me with their mechanic vision?
I already used up my cooldown, chat.
Like, it's not my fault.
My cooldown is just used up.
Guys, I'm just like you.
I'm just like all the other mechanics out there.
Why can't I...
I just ulted too early!
I'm building up my ult charge!
Why is none of this working?
What am I missing?
Oh no!
No, don't fall down!
Oil pan...
Wait, does it go up top?
No.
Okay.
No, that's not it.
Oh!
Oh, there we go!
Yes!
I knew it.
See, guys?
My mechanic vision worked.
Why won't you go in?
I don't understand.
They gave me a check mark.
Why don't you go in?
Be friends with each other.
Love each other!
Oh no, everything is falling apart!
Love each other now, please!
Oh my god.
Why is there so many flies?
Is this supposed to go anywhere?
I can't tell.
Did I fuck it up?
How do I put this inside?
Oh no.
Okay.
How do I put you inside?
It's probably like an extra piece like Lego, right?
Probably is.
Why won't it go inside?
Which one is the cover?
Is this the cover?
Might be like Lego, right?
Okay.
Is that the cover?
Oh my god.
Why won't you fit?
I feel like you're supposed to be in here.
But why won't you fit in?
Oh!
It goes between the piston and the shaft?
So I have to take out more pieces?
Oh, it'll be fine.
We don't need it.
It'll be fine.
It's just one part.
Like, it'll be fine.
Some cars can be fine.
Oh no, is that my mom?
Is that my mom?
Hello?
Hello, grandma!
What would happen if I don't feed my grandma?
Does she die?
Does grandma die if I don't give her fish?
She'll be okay.
She can eat other stuff.
She doesn't need my help.
Alright.
She won't starve.
Oh, I'm gonna fucking die of thirst though.
She'll be fine, guys.
Guys, it's not my fault my grandma dies.
That means my parents don't care about her enough.
Okay.
I'm gonna drink my water.
Give me a sec, guys.
I gotta hydrate.
Alright.
I'm gonna eat my sausages.
Oh, I'm running out of groceries.
Guys, why is her life under my hands?
If anything, her son should have taken care of her.
I'm fucking trying to build a car right now!
Alright, who fucking cares?
We don't need that.
Alright.
We're almost done with the engine part.
I'm pretty sure this part is not as important.
And you know what?
This is so unimportant
that I'm just gonna put it here.
Now it's like I never had that part.
It's like I never had it.
I'm joking.
It's fine.
You see, as if I... Guys, a camshaft is not that important, guys.
If I know anything about cars and I am a mechanic, a camshaft is like Lego.
You know when they give you extra pieces and it's optional?
It's not that important.
I gotta make sure my car fits the way that it should be.
Yeah, there's so many other shafts inside it.
What's one less shaft?
That's critical.
Wait, I can glitch it in?
Okay, say less.
I'll brute force myself into this.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure...
Oh, wait.
I did it!
God, I'm so talented.
I truly am the greatest mechanic of all time.
Can your mechanic do that?
I cannot get forced apart and will have it taken apart.
I wish life was that easy.
That's when you know I was truly born to be a mechanic.
Can I put this on now?
I'm one of the chosen ones.
The prophecy was right.
Okay.
I'm the chosen one.
Now what?
Timing cover?
What the fuck?
What other stuff am I missing?
Okay, there we go.
We have more shafts in.
Okay.
Okay, that's way too easy, Doki.
Come on, you're better than this.
Your channel is much more highbrow than this.
I know you wanna say it, Doki, but come on.
You can do better.
Okay.
I saw a checkmark for this.
I don't know what this is.
No, it's not.
There we go.
I have no idea what I... Oh, there we go.
It works.
That's all I have to wait until I see a checkmark.
I'm just gonna ram it in.
Okay.
Wiring mess.
Headers.
Radiator.
I'm still at the fucking engine.
When will this...
Oh my god.
Okay, brake master cylinder.
Clearly, that should be something, right?
Just like your local doctor.
Force it until it works.
Okay.
What other stuff will it need?
Is this all right?
Is this everything?
Oh, I feel like I should start screwing things in though.
Right?
Is it tied?
I don't see any screws.
Like, how am I supposed to know which fucking wrench it is for which screw?
Like, it doesn't even...
The sizes aren't even that accurate!
Okay.
Is that it?
No.
You don't...
Like, it doesn't even...
When it's in my hand, why does it...
Okay, wait, do I start screwing this?
I don't know if I start screwing this.
This one goes here.
At least we know this one goes here.
Where does the water pump go in here?
Where do you go?
It doesn't give me a check mark.
Everything came to me in a dream.
No!
No, this...
No, you guys were meant to be!
What happened?!
There we go.
What the fuck do I do now?
Wait, why can't I pick you up?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna freak out.
I'm gonna fucking...
I can't even pick it up anymore!
It won't let me pick...
Oh my god, who's calling me now?!
Who is it?
Oh my god.
It's just telemarketers, guys.
It doesn't matter.
Oh my god.
Why can't I pick up my engine?
It won't even let...
Oh, there it is.
Why am I still at this part?!
I'm gonna bolt this down for now.
And then...
Okay, that's bolted down.
Like...
Where...
Oh my god, where are things supposed to go?
Yes, I'm still building the fucking engine?!
A genius takes time in their work of art.
You don't tell DaVinci that you have a one hour deadline to make the Mona Lisa.
This is my Mona Lisa right now.
An hour spent on me.
This is my Mona Lisa!
I'm literally painting the Great Cathedral... The mural of the Great Cathedral right now.
Did you know the mural in the Great Cathedral of Notre Dame took like 20 to 30 years to paint?
That's right!
And you're trying to rush the process?
You're trying to rush God's gift to the world?
Weird witnessing art.
Alright.
Okay.
Duck, thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Here we see a streamer in their most hostile environment.
A blue-collared job, which is, as the most mechanically illiterate person you've ever seen, trying to cast like Chaplin.
And to believe it, they can put together a car.
WOOOOOO!
Okay.
Thank God there's no fall damage.
I would've been so sad if that is how I was gonna go.
Holy fuck.
Thank God.
I glitched into the car.
The car threw me off.
The car rejected my existence.
They're like...
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Sorry.
The car like rejected my existence there.
But other than that, everything's fine.
Everything is so fucking fine.
Just finish things, you know?
You don't pick the car.
The car picks you.
You can't rush that guy from Toy Story 2.
Thank you for the super chat Neppers.
Thank you.
What am I missing?!
Why does car- Why do cars have so many parts?
I don't understand.
It should be like DUPLO.
Cars should just be like DUPLO where everything is just like three parts.
Where do I fit this?
Apparently I'm supposed to fit some oil- Oh, the oil filter.
Like, where would the oil filter go?
The clutch is not part of the oil filter.
The engine?
But everything is part of the engine.
It's all engine.
That's what the engine is.
The engine is the car.
How can it not be part of the engine?
Oh my god.
Do I add a chain to it?
Does it want a metal chain?
It does.
He feels a little gangster.
Giving him a silver chain to make him feel good.
There's no more gears.
What kind of gears am I missing?
I put every gear possible into this fucking car.
The drive gear?
Oh my god.
What other gear does it need?
A cover?
There's another cover?
Oh, there is.
My TV?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
I forgot to turn off my TV.
How do I still have zero channels?
Do I need to pay for cable?
Alright.
So now that we got the cover on this...
Can I add more stuff to it now?
Oh my god.
What other things can I add?
Do the fins not have...
Do the fins need to pay for cable?
Also, I don't know if the sound has been...
I'm sorry, sound guy.
But do I need to turn anything up?
Or have you guys just been hearing me scream with zero sound?
What the fuck did I...
Okay, if it works, it works.
I don't know how that worked, but it worked.
It still doesn't fit.
It still won't fit.
I don't understand.
Why do you reject him?
I don't understand why you reject him.
Come on.
He's like a part of you.
Okay, nope.
I will force you to love each other.
If it's the last thing I do.
Come on.
Come on, love each other.
If I can glitch a stick into you, I can glitch this into you.
There we go.
Okay, that's definitely not in.
Oh my god.
This one is like the one gear that wouldn't fit in.
It actually is rejecting the full engine.
I don't understand.
I don't understand why you reject each other.
Like, I can't figure it out.
It just doesn't fit.
Do I have to unbolt it?
I don't have anything that works with this.
Oh my god.
I found the wrench.
I fucking did it.
It's like making her...
Piss, damn you!
Piss!
Okay.
Alright, we did it.
We fucking figured it out.
I fucking did it.
Alright.
And now you guys should be able to kiss now.
Now kiss.
Oh my god, I fucking did it.
I made them kiss.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking doing it.
Okay.
Finally.
Now I need to bolt the other stuff down.
Okay, bolt this.
Unbolt that.
That's right.
Get your camcorders out.
We did it, boys.
Now they'll be happy together forever.
Alright.
Then we bolt this down.
And this down.
Oh my god, there's so many bolts.
Like, I feel like I can just bolt half of it and it'll be fine.
Like, it's not gonna come apart or anything.
Cause like...
Like I said, if I just stuffed the entire hood of the car with things, it can't fall apart.
Because everything's pushing each other together, right?
It's like, Oh, if I forget to screw one little thing, my car fucking explodes.
That can't be right.
My fellow mechanics will vouch for me.
That's why all your cars is only partially screwed down.
Alright.
Is it over?
Is the engine done?
Did I do it?
There's no way there's more stuff to this engine.
There's no way.
Is that it?
Why is it stuck?
Oh, guys.
Guys, I think my water pump is stuck, guys.
Guys.
I'm a bit worried.
I'm a bit worried cause I cannot pick up the water pump.
Don't worry, if I bolt it down, maybe...
I'm not so close.
Oh, there you go.
Where do I put this?
Where the fuck does this part go?
What am I missing from this car?
Alright, where's the manual?
Guys, I know what I'm doing, but I wanna show you guys what I'm doing.
You know, with the manual.
I wanna show you guys my thought process to show you guys that everything is going okay.
Guys, I know exactly what I'm doing, but I think you guys don't know what I'm doing, so I'm trying to make sure you know exactly what's going on.
Where's the manual, guys?
There is no...
Okay.
See, guys?
That was a test, everybody.
Cause, like...
If you're like, yeah, oh my god!
Then you're not a real mechanic.
Quit your day job.
Alright.
Actually, don't quit your day job.
It was a test, guys.
I wanna know who the fucking quitters are.
Who are fake mechanics in my chat?
Guys, I don't know if I'm strong enough.
Guys...
I don't know if I'm strong enough.
I need to go...
I need... I'm gonna go buy cigarettes.
I fucking can't.
I can't.
How do I...
The fuck do I even...
How do I get on my own bike?
I can't even sit on my...
Oh, no.
I'm clicking everything!
I can't even sit on my bike!
I need them.
Ow!
Does it enter?
Guess not enter.
Okay, fuck.
How do I do it?
Am I on it?
Okay.
Vroom!
Hey, wait.
Please.
Please, for the love of God.
Please!
Vroom!
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna fucking crash right now.
Driving controls.
Vehicle controls.
Space.
Shift.
Lights.
Auto.
Boost.
Oh, my God.
Vroom!
Is that it?
Is it on?
Oh, it's full.
The fuel is full.
Vroom!
I don't understand.
How do I kick start it?
It's just...
I'm trying my best to rev it!
Vroom!
Oh, my God.
I don't understand.
Why won't you vroom?
What am I missing?
Okay.
Throttle.
W.
Key?
There's no keys on this bike!
Like...
Oh, my God.
Vroom?
How much more?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Vroom!
What am I missing?
What am I...
How do I put this fucker in here?
No, get out of the kick start!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Shift.
Oh, my God.
I have to...
I have to do this again.
Oh, my God!
Vroom!
Okay, where do I go?
Where do I go?
I assume this is where the store is.
Oh, my God.
We're vrooming.
Oh, I'm so thirsty.
Oh, am I going the right way?
I don't know if I'm going the right way!
I'm just gonna follow the road.
Wait, it's the wrong way?
All of the trees... Okay, it's the other way.
Okay.
Okay, I'm really thirsty, guys.
This is really bad.
This is actually really bad.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now that I know how to... Now that I know how to drive...
Now that I know... Okay.
Alright.
I need to get off.
How do I get off?
How do I...
I need to get off.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, let me go get a drink first.
I need to go get a drink before I fucking crash out.
Alright, let me turn on this.
And then...
Slurp, slurp, slurp, slurp, slurp.
Alright.
And then we'll buy some cigarettes now.
Alright, we'll figure out how to vroom.
Alright.
Oh, I can!
Okay, let me start lowering the stress a little bit.
Alright, it's vroom time.
I told you, if you say vroom loud enough, it works.
God, this is...
Okay.
Stand off.
There we go.
Vroom.
Vroom!
Alright, am I going the right way?
Am I going to the store now, guys?
Am I heading...
Alright, left, door, right.
Is this the store?
That has to be the store, right?
Alright.
I'm zooming.
Who lives there?
Is this the store?
Oh no, it was left.
That's alright.
Slow and steady.
We make our own roads.
Guys.
I'm far from the store?
It's fine.
It's fine, we make our own roads.
There we go.
The store is 20 miles away?
How am I supposed to know where the store is?
Alright, vroom.
I just wanted cigarettes.
It can't be that long, guys.
Shift up?
I don't know what shift up does.
Why do I live in the middle of nowhere?
Where are my parents?
It's been two days.
I think...
There's no way my grandma dies.
There's no way.
If she's really starving, she'll order Uber Eats.
In the rural area.
Am I faster now?
Can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm going faster.
Am I going faster?
Guys, I just realized I did not wear my helmet, guys.
Oh, this is bad.
I'm sorry for anybody who's getting motion sickness right now.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, guys.
Guys, I realized I did not wear my helmet, guys.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, no.
I'm getting motion sickness.
Oh, this ain't looking so good.
Oh, my God!
If you pause the game, you don't pause the game!
It'll be fine.
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
See?
Look at that.
I think I can look at my menu while I'm riding my...
I cannot look at my menu.
I cannot look... Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Before...
Which way?
Is it...
Rakipohaja or Lope?
Where could it be?
There's another bike next to me.
I hear another bike.
Is it the right side?
Oh, no.
I gotta...
Alright, there we go.
Oh, no.
It's still...
Okay.
There we go.
I heard another bike next to me.
Oh, my God!
Bike friend!
Is there a bike friend?
Wait, it's the other side?
Which way is this?
Is it...
Some people...
Okay, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
No.
I can't do this.
Why?
I...
Please!
Oh, I give up.
I'm going back home.
I'm...
I'm going home.
I gotta...
I'm going back home.
I can't...
Am I even close?
I'm walking back home.
I'm stressed.
I can't.
I can't do this anymore.
I'm going home.
I can't do this.
Please!
I'm so stressed out.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
I'm so stressed.
Oh my god.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
He needs to be fed.
He's hungry.
He's like, if you're gonna cry, at least feed me first.
I'm sorry.
He's so smart.
He's like, she's having a breakdown.
It's my time to strike now.
She's weak.
And he knows it.
He knows that I am weak.
Oh my god.
He sensed the weakness.
He was like, that's it.
Now she now she'll do anything.
Wait, did I went the wrong way?
Is this back where I came from?
This is where home is.
I'm so tired and I'm dirty.
And my car still haven't finished the engine.
I I haven't I haven't even finished the engine.
I'm not picking up my bike.
I don't care anymore.
I just wanna go home.
I don't need the bike.
I'm tired.
The bike is falling.
I'm stressed.
I'm tired.
I'm dirty.
I just wanna finish the engine.
I
I I I
I I I I I I I I I I'm malnourished as hell too.
I'm like so malnourished right now.
I'm dirty.
I need food.
Hello sir, can you help me?
I need to find my way home.
Can you help me sir?
Okay, he doesn't give a fuck about me.
I don't even know how to interact with him.
Oh my...
Water, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fell asleep to the stream.
It was the most hilarious stream.
Just Doki screaming and laughing.
Made my stream so hysterical.
Love you Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Water, thank you, thank you.
Where is everybody?
Do I not have neighbors?
Please, I just want a car.
How do I get...
I don't even have an engine.
Okay, give it to me straight guys.
Is my engine even like...
Is it even like 30% done?
Like I need a...
No, can I drink?
Oh wait, that's not water.
That's just texture.
That's just fucked up texture.
That's literally just tree PNG right here.
No.
What is...
How far is my engine?
I'm like...
I'm 50%?!
There's no way.
There's no way I'm just 50% done.
I piece so much of the engine.
I piece so much.
There's no way.
Please, I'm so hungry.
My parents left me.
There has to be a car.
Where are any of...
I just...
I just wanted to finish the engine.
Why can't the en...
Why can't it just be like IKEA?
I wish they deport me to Sweden.
At least I get a...
At least it be simple to build like an IKEA chair.
At least...
At least I can build it like...
I want an IKEA engine.
An IKEA...
You know, I'm surprised IKEA hasn't made an IKEA car yet.
I'm really surprised.
I think...
I think if like IKEA made their own IKEA car...
It would be so affordable.
And like...
Less potential to explode.
Versus a Cybertruck.
I think.
As long as there's like less possibilities to explode like a Cybertruck.
I think it's like a win.
Don't care IKEA car will need you.
Exactly.
If I'm gonna build my own fucking car.
Might as well go to IKEA.
That's not a hype part.
Also, I found it very hilarious that...
People found out that...
I mean...
Oh no, I'm gonna die.
Can I drink lake water?
Guys, what happens if I drink lake water?
It won't be that bad, right?
Guys, can I...
Okay, good.
I'm gonna head to the lake.
Oh my god, I'm gonna head to the lake, guys.
I'm gonna head over there.
Oh my god, I hope I don't like sleep in...
I mean like brain-eating amoeba.
Like it's just...
It's like gambling.
Guys.
You gotta take risk.
Not every lake can have brain-eating amoebas.
Am I drinking it?
How do I drink it?
Guys, why won't it let me drink it?
I hope I go faster though.
Guys, it's not letting me drink.
Wait, I can drink?
You guys told me I can drink lake water!
Oh my god.
But it's faster.
It was faster though.
I'm gonna swim.
I'm gonna swim home.
It is faster though.
Swimming home is faster than walking.
They're a bunch of liars.
Please!
I worked so hard on the end!
They can't do this to me!
Why did I leave my bike?
Why did you stop me, chat?
Why did you stop me?
I didn't even save!
Okay, I should be close, right?
Am I close?
Am I even close to home?
You got away.
If grandma has to die, then so be it.
Oh no, I should have followed the road.
I'm lost now.
I think...
Oh my god.
I don't even know if I'm close to home.
Am I even close to home?
I can't even tell!
I have a PNG wall blocking me!
I have a tree PNG blocking me from the road!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
Why did my parents leave me alone?
I don't understand!
Why would they just leave?
Wait, I'm close!
I'm close by!
I'm so close to home, guys!
Guys!
This is just a survival...
Guys, I remembered those houses!
Guys, there's my house!
Oh my god, there's civilization!
There it is!
I'm gonna make it!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's right there!
Wait, that's not my home.
Which way was home?
Oh, there it is!
There it is right here!
It's right there!
I'm gonna make it!
I went to the wrong house, but I'm gonna make it home!
I'm gonna make it home!
I'm gonna drink!
Turn on the tap water!
Drink!
Drink like your life depends on it!
Drink like it!
Oh god, I'm gonna do it!
Okay.
I got it.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew I was gonna live.
Called me.
What the fuck was that?
Alright, now I gotta sleep.
Alright, sleep time!
Sleep time!
We live.
I knew it, guys.
I fucking knew I couldn't live.
Alright.
Wait, who's calling me this late at night?
Who's that?
Who the fuck is that?
Oh, is that my uncle?
Alright, goodbye.
Sorry, uncle.
I gotta figure out how to fucking build my...
I gotta figure out how to build my engine first.
Oh no, I'm about to starve.
This is not good.
I don't know if I...
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's good.
We fixed that, but this is literally my last meal.
Oh, it's my last meal.
We gotta build an engine before it's too late.
Okay, and then...
Alright.
Okay, it's time.
It's thermostat time.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
We're gonna build our engine.
We gotta take a shower first.
But I'll be clean a little bit longer.
Oh my god.
But...
It's okay.
I'm gonna be clean a little bit.
And then I'll pee in the shower to raise...
It's okay.
I'm gonna raise productivity by peeing in the shower while taking a shower.
So I don't waste money.
It's alright.
Look at me being productive right now.
Okay, and then...
Oh my...
You know what, fuck it.
I don't need the sauna.
It's fine.
You know what, fuck it.
We don't need the sauna, guys.
I think it'll be fine.
I think if I just keep swearing...
If I just keep swearing like 24x7...
Things will be okay.
Okay, I just realized I have no light.
Might as well do the sauna.
Until the sun comes up.
Nevermind.
Because the sun isn't up yet.
I might as well do the sauna until then.
So I'll be less stressed out.
Alright, guys.
Be real with me.
How much do I have left for the engine?
Just be real with me, guys.
How bad is it?
How bad is it, guys?
You're giving me so different numbers, guys.
I can't tell.
I can't tell how bad it is.
Not terrible?
70%?
Alright.
Alright, so it'll be fine.
You're like 10%.
Okay, just the engine.
I don't care about the rest of the car, guys.
I just...
I just need...
If we finish the engine, it's a fucking win in my book.
Okay?
Finishing the engine is a fucking win.
I'm gonna say it.
We're just gonna finish the engine.
That's...
That's it.
We win the game if we have a workable engine.
I believe in us.
As long as the engine works, it should be fine.
It should be fine.
That's all we need.
We just need the engine, guys.
To be fair, a car doesn't need anything else.
If a car...
A car can just be an engine...
A car can literally just be an engine and wheels.
Like, what else does it need?
And...
And maybe a steering wheel.
Legitimately, I could just drive a car with just an engine and wheels.
As long as it goes vroom vroom.
Who needs brakes, guys?
I'll just make...
I'll just slow down.
Do we really need brakes if I just slow down the car, you know?
It'll be fine.
Is it warmed up yet?
Is it working?
I can't tell.
The PP is still at 40-30 degrees.
You can't cut funding, you'll regret this.
Tell that to Honda.
During 2010.
Sorry, please Honda, don't go after me.
Yeah,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's oddly specific.
Yeah, imagine your Uber showed up and it was a car.
Oh, it's Toyota?
Alright, it could be any car brand.
To be fair, I think every car brand had that issue.
I'm pretty sure.
Let me look.
I'm pretty sure it's just not...
It's not just...
It's not just Toyota.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Controversy.
Wait, in 2023.
Honda recalled 500,000 vehicles in the US and Canada.
Due to front seat belts that could break open in a crash.
Okay, this was 2023, guys.
Wait, what happened in 2023?
In 2023, Honda recalled about 4.5 million vehicles globally due to fuel pump failures.
In 2023, Honda recalled 249,000 in the US due to a defect in the engine crankshaft.
How much in 2023 were filed against Honda for defective electric power steering systems?
Oh my god, excuse me.
Okay, so I was like, um, doki, that was Toyota.
That's just...
Sorry, I'm talking about...
It's not just...
Let me go with Toyota.
Let me call it Toyota, too.
So, like, we hit all the benchmarks.
We're never getting the Honda sponsor now.
Guys, what happened...
Guys, we never talked about...
Everyone...
Guys, forget...
We never talked about it, guys.
It happened for, like, 30 seconds in one stream.
Surely, my history won't catch up on...
Surely, no one's gonna use this against me, right, guys?
Oh my god.
Nobody's gonna keep receipts, right, guys?
I'm here to build my car.
After everything I say, it's the Honda that gets me.
None of these things you wanted to include in your car.
Um, excuse me.
It was the crankshaft gear.
Guys, I even got to the seatbelt part of my car.
And you were damn right I wasn't gonna include seatbelts.
Alright.
Am I less stressed now?
Alright, there we go.
Is this good?
Okay, I'm still stressed out.
Jesus Christ.
Can't believe it.
I'm still fucking stressed out.
Okay, what if I do sauna and also swear?
Then maybe, like, I get to complete both things.
It's okay, we can still get the Hugo Sponsor shit.
Maybe Toyota will sponsor me after, you know?
Toyota?
Maybe I can get the Toyota sponsor from that.
It'll be like, woah.
You know what?
Or maybe BMW.
BMW, Subaru, Chevrolet, Toyota, Hyundai, Ford.
Okay, guys.
I'm not blacklisted there.
You ain't BMW.
What makes somebody BMW material?
Like...
It's awkward for anybody that made a Doki Tasha Honda car now.
They're like, woah.
Okay, now I should be good, right?
Alright, let's see.
Let me crank that down.
Alright, I should be okay now.
I'm less stressed now.
Alright, is it daytime yet?
I was in the sauna for a while now.
How dark is it outside?
No, it's still- Oh wait, no, it's starting to get brighter.
Alright.
Oh wait, I forgot to close the fridge door?
Oh my god, there's like a lot of things I've forgotten.
Oh my god, you're right.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, and I need a drink.
Slurp, slurp, slurp.
Okay.
Alright.
Everything should be fine now.
I should be okay, guys.
Oh, it's still so dark.
Do I have lights in the garage?
I do.
Alright, guys.
What else do I need- Guys, we just gotta finish the engine.
That's our goal.
That's literally- We just need to finish the engine.
And we'll be- Just, please.
Please.
I just- I just wanna finish my engine.
That's all I want in life.
Please.
It just- What do we need?
The top part?
What's- Is this the top?
Is it this?
Why is it not screwed yet?
Spark plugs and alternator belt?
What is that?
Inspection cover, battery.
Don't have spark plugs here.
You guys are saying lots of words, guys.
You guys- You guys are saying a lot of words.
Oh, alternator.
But where does the alternator go?
Where the fuck does it go?
There's no- There's no check marks anywhere.
Where?
On the engine?
Silly.
Oh, wait.
There's a check mark.
I have no idea where you're supposed to go.
But I saw a check mark in here.
Where is it?
I know you exist.
I know you- Oh.
Right here.
Oh my god, I did it.
Oh my god.
You're a fucking genius, Doki.
Okay, alternator.
And then I need a belt of some sort.
Should be here somewhere.
I saw that belt.
Should be here.
Handbrake.
Oh, we don't need that.
Bracer.
We don't need that.
I shouldn't say- I shouldn't say what I was gonna say.
I had to buy a belt?!
Okay, what do I have that's here?
Is there anything else?
Is there anything else I can put on this engine that's here?
Did I do it?
Timing belt and timing covers.
Oh my god.
Where is that?
Oh, oh.
Timing covers.
Should be this, right?
Should go over there.
Oh.
Timing belt.
Okay, okay.
I need a tool.
Make sure everything's bolted down.
Is this bolted down?
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, this is bolted.
I don't know what's a pulley, guys.
I don't know what's a pulley.
I don't know what you mean when you say pulley.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
I don't- what's the pulley?
They all look the same.
Everything just looks the same.
Alright.
Wait, I saw a check mark.
Okay.
There we go.
It should go in somewhere.
Where should this go?
Stop crying.
A mechanic doesn't cry.
What's the pulley?
None of this says pulley.
What the fuck do you mean, pulley?
Like, what?
Take off the crankshaft?
The fuck you mean, crankshaft?
Mechanics never cry.
Oh my god.
Blue circle.
There's a blue circle hole?
It's just all grey.
It's just all grey with occasional gold.
Oh my god.
God, just deport me.
Just deport me from Finland.
Oh my god.
Just deport me.
I can't.
I fucking can't.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm not.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
I'm so fine.
Everything will be okay.
Everything.
What the fuck does this mean?
I can't.
What does this mean?
I'm using mechanical vision and I...
What does this...
What does this mean?
What does all of this mean?
I can't...
Even if I actually followed this, I...
I can't even...
I can't even process any of this.
What does that mean?
Even if I actually looked up a tutorial, I can't...
I...
I can't even figure this out.
I don't even know where I'm at anymore.
Where am I at in this fucking stupid ass engine?
I can't.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so okay, everyone.
I'm okay, guys.
Oh my god, guys.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Whoa.
Sorry.
My game feed, it like flickered off.
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened?
My game feed.
Don't worry.
I can fix this, guys.
Wow.
I can...
I did it, guys.
I fucking did it.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I built the engine.
I...
Oh my god.
I fucking...
I...
Oh my god.
I figured it out, everybody.
I...
Guys, it only took me three hours and I did it.
I built...
I built my engine, everyone.
You guys thought I couldn't do it.
But look who's laughing now.
I...
Oh my god.
That's right.
All live on stream.
Right here.
Right now.
It only took us three hours.
And oh my god.
Let me...
Oh my...
Wait.
Sorry.
Watch this.
Whoa.
Okay.
All right.
Watch this, guys.
I'm going to show you guys.
I'm holding my engine.
You don't see it, guys.
You don't see it right now.
But I'm holding my engine now, guys.
The engine is being held right now.
And I'm going to put everything together.
And then...
Oh my god.
It's going to be so crazy.
I'm going to put this engine in.
Watch this, everyone.
Watch this.
All right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let me...
Let me make sure I'm right here.
And watch this crazy-ass glitch that I'm going to show you guys.
I found out this super crazy glitch while I was reading that manual real quick.
Watch this.
Okay.
You see...
You see that yellow car right there?
Look.
Give me a sec.
You see that yellow car?
Whoa.
Okay, okay.
Oh, sorry.
The glitch requires me to, like, flicker...
Do a special thing that flickers it in and out.
And then, like...
Oh my god!
What?!
Did it!
I made my car!
Oh my god!
No way!
Yeah, it's yellow!
Just like a god!
I fucking did it, guys!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
I fucking did it!
It took...
Oh my god!
I knew I was a real mechanic, guys.
I knew...
I knew I was a real mechanic, everyone.
It...
Oh...
My god.
Oh, it only took me so long.
It only took me three hours to piece everything together.
But I fucking knew it, guys.
I knew it.
I knew there was hope for me.
I don't have to get deported, guys.
I...
Oh my god.
I get to live in Finland.
I'm so happy.
I get to...
I get to stay in Finland.
Chat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on building your car.
You don't have to be deported.
I get to stay.
I passed my test.
No name.
What's the broken yellow thing on the bottom?
There's no...
What do you mean?
It's a full car.
Right?
That's perspective, guys.
It's just perspective.
Thank you for the super chat.
No name.
Thank you, thank you.
Zekra, good job, Doki.
Now time to...
Oh, you think I won't be able to drive it?
Oh, yeah?
Alright, don't worry, guys.
Give me a sec.
Give me...
Sorry.
It's so weird.
This glitch has a thing where, like...
Like, because I...
Because, like, I figured out a way to put an engine in it.
And...
Put an engine in it.
And then, like, everything...
There was a special glitch you can do where everything else just comes together.
So, like, it just finishes.
But when you finish the engine and you do the special glitch, everything comes together.
But it happens so fast that there's a little bit of lag.
So, like, just give me a sec, guys.
I'm waiting for the lag to, like...
I'm just waiting for the lag right now to, like, balance it out.
So it catches...
So I can actually move in the game right now.
So that's why it's, like, buffering at the moment.
Because of the lag at the moment.
Because, like, you know, it's trying to compensate for all the stuff that was happening earlier.
So, give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Because, like, you know...
Okay, you guys are gonna see some really weird lag real quick, guys.
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh, oh my god.
Alright, there's the car.
I took the car to the...
I pushed the car to the road.
Alright.
Oh, oh my gosh.
The lag.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, woah!
What happened to the car?
It disappeared!
Oh, don't worry.
That's just the lag.
It's just, like, I went closer to the car and, like, clicked on it.
So, I'm gonna get in the car right now, guys.
I'm just gonna get in the car right now, okay?
I'm gonna get...
Guys,
it's just a special kind of lag, okay?
There we go.
Oh my god!
I'm in my car!
Vroom!
Vroom, everyone!
We made our car!
Vroom, vroom!
We did it, everyone!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's working!
Why is...
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Now, it's driving correctly, guys.
No way!
Vroom, vroom!
Whoa!
Sick trip!
It's working, guys!
It's working!
Vroom!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, you don't hear the engine?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
I turned down my...
I turned down the volume, guys.
I turned it down.
Give me some...
Let me turn it up because, like, sound guy was like, you should turn...
You should turn the volume...
The volume is just right.
But, like, obviously, we gotta turn up the volume right now.
So...
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, guys.
Watch this.
Alright.
It should be good.
Alright, you guys hear it now?
Whoa!
Vroom!
Okay, here we go.
Vroom, vroom, vroom!
Vroom!
Whoa!
We're doing it!
This car...
Guys, look.
It's just getting...
It's revving up, guys.
It's just revving up, everyone.
Guys, it's a little shy.
It's a little shy.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
Okay, let me...
Let me...
Let me fix, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm fixing the car.
Let me...
I'm gonna...
Let me get out real quick and fix this car, guys.
Let me...
Alright.
Let me get out real quick, guys.
I'm...
Don't worry.
I'll...
I'm gonna smack it and then it'll go faster.
I promise.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna smack it so it'll go faster, guys.
There we go.
And then I'll be like...
Alright, there we go.
Alright, let me...
Let me get back in.
Let me get back...
Okay.
Okay, now it should be faster, right?
Alright.
Don't worry.
Just like...
There we go.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
This should be fine, right?
Alright.
Don't worry.
Come on.
Come on, don't be shy.
There we go.
Woah!
We did it!
It's so fast!
It's so fast, everyone!
Woah!
This is so...
Guys, I'm so proud of ourselves, chat.
That we managed to make a car.
And we did it, everyone.
We should turn around and head back home, though.
Let me drive back home.
Damn.
Alright, guys.
Alright, I think this is a good time to call it.
We did it!
We made our car!
We did it, everyone!
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew we could do it, chat.
I knew we could make our fucking car.
You know what?
I've always believed in us.
All the way till the end.
Where are my believers at?
Where are you guys?
Who believed in me?
I knew you guys would've believed in me.
That's a nice car.
Who witnessed greatness today, everyone?
Thank you, thank you.
Doubters, we won.
No, no, no.
That's right, doubters.
That's fucking right.
Doubters, an absolute shambles after today.
We were all here.
Oh my god.
What a wild ride.
I crashed out several times today, but it's okay.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
But...
But it doesn't mean...
It doesn't mean it's over.
Because we do have another stream tonight, guys.
We do have another stream.
We have another stream in like two hours.
So I'll be doing some Twitch Rivals practice after that.
But also, I did try to show something.
But if you guys want to get Oshie Sparks merch from the concert.
The Phantom Thief concert.
We are having pre-orders open.
And I believe it ends the end of January.
So if you want to order some of the stuff from the concert.
Even if you haven't been to the concert.
Please pre-order them for memory's sake.
It was my very first concert.
Did I misspell it?
Did I?
No.
It fucking leads there.
Anyway, guys.
Also other stuff to show.
My Nendoroid, my gamer subcode, Fortnite code.
Miko Hatsune just came out on Fortnite.
So you should use my creator code.
It really just means that I get a little bit of the purchases.
From whatever you make on Fortnite.
It doesn't add any extra to your purchases.
I just get a little bit more.
I just get some from you supporting me.
Fortnite just gives me a little bit of the percentage.
From the skins you buy.
In the Fortnite store.
So just use Doki Bird.
If you are buying a Miko Hatsune skin on Fortnite.
Or any of the cosmetics.
Alright, guys.
My brain hurts from trying to piece...
My brain...
I'm not going to lie.
That was actually really stressful.
So my brain hurts a little.
Trying to piece everything together.
So I'm going to...
I'm going to...
I'm going to rest a little bit.
Maybe we'll try again.
One day we'll finish the car again.
One day we'll do a glitchless run.
Chat.
A glitchless run.
Like we glitched our car into it.
But we will do a glitchless run in the future.
I promise you guys that.
Anyway.
So I'm going to...
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your chat.
Get up and move around.
And get that blood flowing.
And if you...
For me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys on Twitch later.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.